for the second year in a row as part of  the New York Comedy Festival  we're taking our show on the road to New  York City very excited about yeah that's  right once again we're gonna be doing  shows at the historic Apollo Theater in  Harlem 7 November 6 through the night  cuz when you think Apollo Theater in  Harlem you think this guy right here all  right well anyway yes some we have great  guests coming up great lineup including  Stephen Colbert gonna stop by  keegan-michael key  the cast of Daddy's home to Wilfer Oh  Mark Wahlberg John Lithgow Mel Gibson we  also have we have a special surprise  guest we'll be telling you about later  in the week so be sure to tune in that's  gonna be all next week you do not want  to miss those New York shows there's  gonna be good  [Applause]  you